[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です
a
先に言っておきます
今回は
本当に重大発表です
皆さんは
兄件
僕のヒーローあ建宮というものをご存知
でしょうか
今年からアニメ見てもうドハマリしてもう
ずーっとの一気に今5機まであるんです
けども全部観させていただいてもう大幅に
してしまうくらいも大好きになっちゃった
に目僕のヒーローアカデミアっていうのが
あるんですけども
なんと今回
ここ
はじめしゃちょー同時に
キールが来ておりますどうぞ
ん
[音楽]
アーカンちゃんでくん逆になっちゃった
かんちゃんネックこんにちはこんにちは
自己紹介をお願いします
こんな場合はあ
緑やに就く
ヒーローがやってますね
おお俺が
学童担ぎらー
ああああああああ
ありがとうございますが我が家に来て
下さって結構
ハーフ ok だねそれでもいやーもう
ホンダ始めたいすぎて某まで開かために
決めしたね良い期から5期まで本当に
ハマりまくってるなんかちゃんとみなさん
ヤバイ話ありますという風に皆さんこの
デックんかっちゃん遊びに来てくれた真の
理由ですねー
発表シティ
発表していいかなぁ
強い何度ですねー
僕のヒーローがてみやー
[音楽]
はい政権でしましたーー
遠すぎる
打ったことが実現可能となる t が本当
のヒーの配置してかっちょいいの
うわぁ
ここはえねー
ブログでみなさん何と僕の昼アカデミーは
再審決定しました配信 part なん
ですけども何度今日の夜から始め社長2の
方で配信開始でございます
たgoo
いや
これですねー人にはわからないと思うんだ
けど本当にすごいことなんだよアニーね
youtube チャンネル配信てるって
もすごいんですよ
わかんないよね広さとするからあんまり
アニメ恥辱のはわかって言ったりは数社の
皆さんのちょっとわからないかもしれない
ですけども本当に奇跡的なことが起きて
ましてこれもう
来いよで配信パンなんですけど一気の
ピッチャーから10万中藪連続で配信させ
ていただきますいやもう
すごいですよ
関東見ていっというわけで9月の15日の
木曜日ですね創著2のちゃんねんで1
オーナーから集11期の1話から通話を
毎日配信させていただきます
犬れる真のありがとうございますん
[音楽]
さすがに前はおりでした前はとは言いませ
んもういっちょ中でも相当良いことなんで
排出させて頂けるのぜひ僕のヒーローが文
見たことないよっていう人結構前に見たよ
っていう人はぜひもう一回見て市場から
十分二人ドスって出るものでも大活躍する
しももちろんあると思うんですけども
いろんな関係もいろんな手帖を脱いで日本
の危機的に録画チャンネルで市場から冗談
せていただけることになったので皆さん
是非存分に僕の広がりや楽しんでください
すごい本当にこれがユーチューバーを始め
たときはまさか自分のチャンネルでアニメ
なくせることがあるので思わなかったので
本当にあのう
このたびは墨汁両端実は性差原型の皆さん
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
おっ
というわけで良いよ僕のヒーロー
アカデミー配信が始まるわけなんです
けれどもそしてついに二人ともきましたね
第6期が始まりますよ僕にはアラビア
いやぁーにもたい動機ということでもう超
激薬店街でここから始まるわけなんです
けれども僕のヒーロー赤瀬宮第6期が10
月の1日の土曜日から理由がたくこちら
スタートです毎週土曜日放送しますので
是非皆さんご覧ください
カラーもうすごいもんねー
話がいい
銀座で前が mo
的に1期の1話から中は補助3冊を2-3
年で見ていくわけなんですけれども構成と
して僕も一緒に見させていただきます結構
ほぼ一気にしちゃって一番カズーラの記憶
と空今になってる部分とかもあるのでぜひ
視聴者さんの皆さん初めて見る方も初めて
ちょっと一緒に僕の級のアカデミーを
楽しんでいければいいと思っています旅
やる喋っちゃうと思う
テンションあがりすぎでそれをしケアが
いるんですけど
発表していた
all my とです
米で望遠練ったりの対応ほら2人とも憧れ
の人じゃあおるまいとなんとヒーローの鏡
というか閉じ象徴的な存在なので僕 all
men とが一番好きなんですけども
オールマイティもかなり活躍すると思って
そこもぜひ all my とファンから
すると見てほしいなっているようになり
ますというわけでいよいよ第6期が始まり
ますちょっとさ良い子込みを聞いてみたい
と思いますべくどうでした
[音楽]
ありがとうございますかっちゃま
753気合が入っている曲で僕の昼わけで
第4位そして走り師匠ッで始まり北披露
建宮是非ご覧くださいじゃあ
あっ
[音楽]
はっは